hey we've got one of those aha moments
oh
look at that beautiful sun is uh just
now on the rise and it's kind of
breaking through the clouds out there
to the east those clouds have been with
us overnight and that's actually kept us
pretty mild so we'll look for
temperatures to
increase of course through the day now
that the sun is on its way up these are
our coolest temperatures of the day we
get them right at daybreak
43 up at kyle canyon uh mid 60s out in
summerlin in the lakes
low 60s and centennial hills as we make
our way around the valley
65 at nellis aliante you're cool at 60.
i mean that it's
actually pretty comfortable out there
and we don't really have the wind yet
it's going to get uncomfortable as we
get through the day mid 60s on the strip
near 70
green valley seven hills and henderson
we are so dry and so thirsty
but today is one of those days where
you're probably going to turn off your
sprinklers
to save some water because of the wind i
wanted to share a beautiful picture
john salvi was out for a walk this
weekend took a gorgeous shot of a
mesquite tree and he said they have so
much personality they just have lots of
bins and
and kinks in them these are trees that
have really long roots they're very
native to dry desert climates
and they search for water with those
long roots we'll all be searching for
water
and we're going to stay very very dry
we're in a drought of course
and it's getting worse we were way
behind on rainfall last year
this year we're still behind a little
bit and we need more rain but we're
going to stay very dry
and it's those dry conditions along with
these strong gusty winds today
which are going to put us on high fire
alert danger for the desert let's talk
about wind advisories
all these areas of blue all of clark
county and just the southern edges
of lincoln not lincoln county sorry nye
county
also included in that wind advisory that
starts before noon and fire weather
warnings and the reason these are fire
weather warnings is because the humidity
is going to be very low
combined with these strong gusty winds
if a fire should get started today
it could get out of control very easily
with 40 plus mile an hour winds
across some areas today so please be
aware of that 85 today will stay in
those very warm 80s but tomorrow
northerly winds those will turn
overnight and those will help usher in
a little break in those 80s we'll get
into some more normal 70s for a few days
that'll feel good nice relief there and
then we heat back up over the weekend
and even hotter 90s returning next week
we've already had some days in the 90s
for the month of april